FBI director Ray said it's becoming more
and more of a priority for us under oath
just two weeks ago who's lying to us
director Ray or you hey guys I'm off the
grid for August but our Secretary of
Homeland Security Alexander mayorkas
said something ridiculously moronic
surprise surprise there you go the
poster behind me we are seeing all sorts
of very serious very serious criminal
threats that come from across the border
that was two weeks ago from FBI director
Ray in other words saying the border is
out of control you say it's under
control who's lying you or FBI director
Ray Congressman we are very proud of our
average to secure the Border we are
Relentless in our efforts to strengthen
FBI director Ray said it's becoming more
and more of a priority for us under oath
just two weeks ago who's lying to us
director Ray or you Congressman we work
very closely with the FBI to ensure the
safety and security of the American
people that is our highest priority
foreign